ja und das hier ist heute unsere
titelseite so unwürdig sterben unsere
alten im heim ja eine wut brief von
unserem bild reporter willi hand ihres
denn willys onkel peter ist mit 74
jahren verstorben er hatte kroner und
lebte wegen seiner demenz erkrankungen
eben lange in einem altenheim und
deswegen starb er so würdelos wie man
eigentlich nur sterben kann ganz alleine
ohne abschied ohne eine hand die
erhalten konnte und das macht einen
nicht nur traurig sondern auch wütend
und genau darüber möchte ich jetzt auch
mit willi sprechen er ist mir jetzt live
zugeschaltet hallo will erst mal mein
aufrichtiges tiefes beileid für deinen
verlust dankeschön jetzt erzähl uns auch
mal ein bisschen was über dein onkel
peter was war er für ein mensch
peter war der älteste bruder meiner
mutter die wand iks geschwister und ich
würde sagen wir sind eine sehr enge
familie
entsprechend war das immer üblich bei
uns dass vance geburtstage gab wenn es
an weihnachten ging das die ganze
familie zusammen kamen geht es halt dass
da immer vorgelebt und das sagen wir
ganz selbstverständlich dass er für
seine familie für seine frau für seine
kinder für seinen neffen seine
geschwister immer dabei und entsprechend
hat sich das jetzt zum ende meines
lebens umdrehen mussten als er wird aber
als er ins heim musste wegen seiner
tendenz da mussten wir uns um ihn
kümmern das war vorher liegen für seine
jüngeren geschwister eine riesige
umstellung und es hat mal besser mal
schlechter klappt mit ihm er hat uns
alle erkannt hat die großen
sachzusammenhänge der welt nicht mehr
verstanden wer demenzkrank kennt der
weiß schon was ich meine und
entsprechend hat ja auch gar nicht
verstanden was corona eigentlich
bedeutet warum die leute auf einmal alle
masken trugen warum keiner mehr zu ihm
kommen konnte warum
als dann die diagnose aber warum er
nicht mehr von seinem zimmer durfte was
auch diese maske in seinem gesicht soll
hatte eine schlechte sauerstoffsättigung
am ende und erst dann aggressiv geworden
das heißt wie war die situation in dem
altenheim in dem peter gelebt hat das
war ein ausbruch im altenheim die
diagnose kam nach einer routine test
kurz vor weihnachten und es waren
mehrere personen auf dem auf dem flur
auf der station betroffen
die positiv getestet wurden und ab dem
moment wo corona in seinem heim ist ist
die situation für die leute vor ort halt
glücksspiel überlebt oder überlebten
nicht
jetzt sagst du dass du vor allem sehr
viel besser das kann man natürlich 100
prozent nachvollziehen erklären bitte
noch mal genau was macht dich so wütend
einsatz vielleicht noch zum zum einen
damit dass keinen falschen zungenschlag
bekommt
ich bin ich habe wahnsinnigen respekt
vor der arbeit der menschen in
altenheimen meine mutter als
altenpflegerin meine schwester ist
gelernte krankenschwester ich weiß dass
das wort pflegenotstand seine
berechtigung hat in deutschland ich weiß
dass die leute schon fortuna auf dem
zahnfleisch gegangen sind und jetzt
durch corona ist da kein fan vielleicht
mehr das einfach nur blanker näher
da ist nur noch zahlen auf dem man durch
diese virus bedingungen und durch die
arbeit während der pandemie überhaupt
keinen spielraum mehr hat und diese
leute das personal die leitung von
altenheimen die werden halt dermaßen
politisch im stich gelassen ist es
unfassbar 1 es ist ja keine
überraschende situation also wir wissen
seit monaten dass die meisten toten in
deutschland oder die meisten menschen
die an mit oder nach einer cola
erkannten sterben dass die in altenheim
sind in hessen waren es im dezember 86
prozent in nordrhein westfalen
mehr als jeder zweite corona tote der
aus einem altenheim kam und es wurde
nichts unternommen
und diese absolute und finale gewissheit
dass wir in dieser situation sehenden
auges nein gelaufen ohne etwas gemacht
zu haben
die macht mich wahnsinnig wütend als die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mitte
dezember am 13 war es glaube ich
beschlossen hat dass man eine eine
testpflicht strategie aufbauen möchte da
war es erstens schon viel zu spät
da sind unsere alten schon gestorben bzw
waren voll im fokus
und jetzt am 15 januar hat man im
beschluss festgehalten dass das ist
einfach personell warum ich umsetzen
aber was man beschlossen hatte ich habe
mit einer alten heimleiterin ende
dezember telefoniert die hat gesagt das
ist schön dass die politik uns neue
hausaufgaben gibt und tests pflicht
verordnet aber ohne personal klappt das
nicht das ist so als würdest du als
bundesregierung als
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz schönes
wetter verordnet um die sonne sich
selber für man das hat sie gesagt und
das macht mich wahnsinnig mit also zu
recht wütend auf die politik wie geht es
denn jetzt bei dir persönlich weiter am
montag ist die beerdigung und ja das ist
schon heute der gedanke wir haben das
ganze jahr darauf verzichtet und zu
sehen wir haben hochzeit abgesagt wir
haben familien feierlichkeiten abgesagt
geburtstage haben uns acht neun monate
nicht so gesehen und dann treffen wir
uns andere auf einer beerdigung wieder
von einem menschen den wir einen
schützen wollten das ist ganz ganz
bitter
und das ist als angehöriger sich nicht
verabschieden zu können von einem
menschen den man gerne hat ja immer zum
leben dazugehört hat das ist brutal das
fühlt sich hilflos an aber das gefühl
dass da jemand gestorben ist und das
gefühl gehabt haben musst das alleine
war auf dem totenbett auf dem sterbebett
das ist einfach nur unwürdig
deswegen umso mehr vielen dank will dass
du die geschichte heute so öffentlich
mit uns geteilt hast und uns daran
teilhaben hast lassen und noch mal mein
aufrichtiges beileid
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren